so I host the show real kids I will love
it if you guest hosted the goosebumps
episode with me you down you'd be
playing my cousin
I'll take those yes and my still Jack
Black or a ram I carry just between you
and me it's really me Jack Black I'm in
character don't tell anyone I'm dance
cousin Gary you see it doesn't come off
at all just like Donald Trump and so
let's get no don't do it's true okay I
wear a wig but I'm still Gary you guys
guess what you're not gonna believe it
who is this movie perfect for just to
meet well yeah what gives you the goose
bumps
I think slappy hag gave me goose votes
in that movie I get goose bumps when I
have to go to the DMV
cuz I'm terrified of long lines melody
cadence if you had to be a goosebumps
creature which one would you be
or one of the gnomes one of the lawn
gnomes they're indestructible because if
you break them they just they'd build
back together that's pretty cool power
with magic powers what about if you put
them in fire then I guess they melt away
but I think they might still come back
they might have maybe lava that's a
thing but you have to get to a volcano
where you gonna do that
these are all goosebumps manuscripts why
are these books locked did you unlock a
book Oh No
I'm gonna let you come up with some of
your own goosebumps titles and Jack if
you could tell us what that story would
be that would be awesome
melody cadence what's your goosebumps
title blackhat and pokes that's it
that's it that's a great book about
these pipes that are underground all
around the world and there's black cats
in them and the black cats are secretly
controlling the worlds with an
underground computer conspiracy okay
everybody come up with your perfect
goosebumps creature and Jack's gonna act
it out
melody cadence a gigantic fluffy unicorn
that is really very mean that's accurate
Jessica the shoe police who's wearing
the wrong tape a shoe I don't know why
he's I read James goosebumps creature
the monster that eats vampires captain
zombie
hello my name's Gary I eat the blood of
the vampire zombies and kids this is the
way I envisioned it thank you for
joining us guys please see goosebumps
when it hits theaters soon and Jack come
back anytime you want
oh yeah I'll be here every episode maybe
just the ones where we're promoting your
movie that would be weird if you came in
no I'm coming tomorrow I know in the
show now taking my double Jack's kids
we'll see you tomorrow yeah
well that's not getting into the episode
we'll cut that part Dave is not gonna
work
yeah sorry she's not afraid stop-motion
animation
glad you asked stop-motion animation is
that animation stops of course much much
much larger mark very high five
since market strike yeah you'll probably
like night yeah thank you thank you
welcome
you're good